und ein furchtbar schreibens wasser und
zwar von den menschen die in dem schiff
war die im moment wohl das schiff sich
drehte und unterging war das ein
riesenstreit meilenweit zu hören war von
den menschen dort an bord
da habe ich immer noch hin
[Musik]
wegen dieser 30 januar in los so weit es
noch erinnern können also der dreißigste
januar begann damit dass wir aus lauf
termin hatten und und zufälligerweise
natürlich an meinem geburtstag ja
tagsüber liegt alles noch sehr aufgeregt
und und alles mögliche aber zum abend
bin ich dann zur ruhe gekommen und habe
gedacht du hast einige geburtstag und
muss zumindest mal den kuchen in deiner
oma den geschickt hat und alles
probieren und auch mal ein bisschen
klein bisschen festlich gestaltet die
stimmung die menschen waren ruhig also
es war keine aufgeregte stimmung auf dem
schiff also da war keine turbulenz
irgendwie die turbulenz kam nach der
torpedierung und die kam so stark dass
es dann so weit kam dass sogar die
menschen sich gegenseitig getreten und
sogar totgetreten haben auf den gang
nach draußen zu kommen
[Musik]
ja es hat dreimal rummst aber richtig so
dass du so dass du aus deinen sitzt
richtig hoch gedrückt wurde und zweimal
und der kritik kam etwas später da war
dann im maschinen und haben die anderen
beiden kantoren im vorschiff so da bin
ich natürlich dann raus aus manacor
versucht und dann bin ich dann an der
alz lade decke kommen das war demnach
schon eine etage höher und
da habe ich gesehen dass das vorschiff
also schon unter wasser sein muss sie
denn im laden deck war schon wasser und
ich habe dann erst mal versucht was
machst du jetzt und da bin ich ab denn
jeder angekommen versucht man erst nach
oben und da wusste ich dass dieser gang
dort hoch ging von dem für die maschine
ist um sich da rund um das schloss zu
schnappen
dadurch bin ich nach oben und ich war
heilfroh dass ich nachher oben war
erstmal was haben sie gesehen dass hase
was habe ich gesehen wie gesagt ich war
ja auf dem sonnendeck oben und habe mich
da denn aufgehalten die ganze zeit aber
ich habe gesehen dass ein offizier seine
frau und seine kinder erschossen hat und
sich selbst auch solche sachen sind wort
vorgekommen
und da ist das tat das ist das prägt
doch wenn du sowas siehst
und wie ging es dann weiter wenn sie das
schiff also es knallte mal plötzlich auf
dem schiff und dann fängt das schiff an
natürlich sich noch bei der mediation
wie die wassermengen denn überall ein wo
sie bisher noch nicht waren so und das
führte dazu dass es das schon die die
die brücken noch schon schon ins wasser
eintaucht und da habe ich gesagt jetzt
musste verschwinden und der bin ich
rüber auf die andere seite
dann bin ich an steuerbord im
hintergrund dieser nutzte ins wasser
rein so und es ist zu bedenken
es war der 30 januar windstärke 7
einige eisschollen schwamm auf dem
wasser also es war sehr kalt und jemand
der keinen stabilen kreislauf hatte ist
sicher bei dem eintauchen in diese kalte
wasser schon hat dann nicht nein dann
hat das nicht überlebt so und ich bin
habe dann auch noch dass vielleicht
schon zehn minuten nur der finsternis
dauerte nicht lange
da hat man ein bisschen slams in ein
rettungsboot eingezogen
da ist noch der zeitpunkt als dann die
gustloff gegangen
ja und zwar hatte uns ja und er wir
haben getrieben ja und ich habe hier die
gustloff gesehen und dann wie die
us-boys runter ging hat sie sich noch
mal irgendwie aufgerichtet das sah so
aus als wären sie sich einmal ganz in
ihre längsachse gedreht hat aber das
verbot nicht erfahren und ein
furchtbarer schreibens wasser und zwar
von den menschen die in dem schiff war
die im moment wohl das schiff sich
drehte und unterging war das ein
riesenschritt meilenweit zu hören war
von den menschen dort an bord den steuer
habe ich immer noch hin
haben sie erinnerungen an einzelne
personen ein sogenannter tablet
sinzinger das war ein bayer
er spielt jetzt so gut hatte so gitarre
und hat auch mal schön gesungen und wie
ich an bord war auch wie sie mich
rausholen und ich danach uns haben sie
an die nasse kleidung vom leib
geschnitten und uns dann in die
maschinen in den maschinenraum
verfrachtet wo es warm war und wie ich
da an bord da sah ich derselbe sinke der
schwarm auch und wollte hoch greifen
wollte noch sich noch irgendwo
festhalten und sagte dann ab war weg
also form der ist vor meine augen
regelrecht unterging also dann irrtum
das war so man das war so ein
dramatisches kriegsereignisse ansonsten
war ich in keiner frontale irgendwie
lassen hab da irgendwo geschossen oder
gemacht das war ja alles nicht herbei
sofern begünstigt ja die haben mich da
haben uns ja immer einer nach dem
anderen wieder hochgezogen weil so zwei
drei mann haben denn da gestanden und
haben versucht ja die menschen dort
rausholen von sachsen ins aus ging es
dann weiter von sachsen jetzt sind wir
dann nach sind wir dann nach nach mit
der bahn nach kiel gekommen
und da ich ja schiff ist also see funker
war konnte ich mit der land vorgereiht
die man mir angedacht hatte an land ja
nichts anfangen
das feuer völlig was anderes und von
einer ausbildungsstätte nach der zur
anderen wollen wir dann immer getrieben
durch die oder medien aufrückte und
jetzt ging immer weiter westwärts und so
landete ich dann nachher in parchim und
nach crivitz und das ist daher in der
nähe von meinem heimatort gewesen und
habe bin ich eben bin ich
eben entschuldigen gelandet von morgens
um 4 zu hause habe meine oma es gibt
stimmen die sagen ja entschuldigen wenn
sie wollen sie hin
ich hatte mich noch gar nicht mal
erkannt und naja und mittags um zwölf
war der amerikaner mit seinen panzern am
pfaffenteich entschuldigen damit war für
mich der krieg beendet
welcher tag war das wissen sie dass noch
ein fünfter mai sie haben ja selbst
mitbekommen wie die flugbewegungen im
zweiten weltkrieg war sie ein selbst
tausende flüchtlinge mit an bord der
gustloff wie fühlt sich das an was
denken sie wenn sie wenn sie jetzt diese
beiden lebens ereignisse miteinander
vergleichen welche gedanken kommen
hinter da muss ich sagen dass wir uns
mächtig mächtig daneben benehmen
insofern das nehmen wir als beispiel die
unsere ostpreußen flüchtlinge ins
mecklenburgische oder sagen wir mal in
den westen damals kam und der krieg
hatte ja auch es gab ja kaum was zu
essen und die menschen haben ja wirklich
auch teilweise warum hat und so weiter
und da war die solidarität der deutschen
untereinander nicht beispielhaft bis hin
zu unmöglich so und wenn ich den
parallele zu heute mit den flüchtlingen
aus welchen gründen sie auch immer
hierherkommen nicht denn sie mögen
unterschiedlich sein aber sie sind nun
mal hier und es sind menschen das sind
menschen und den gegenüber ist man
zumindest solidarisch müsste man sein
gegenüber also die was ich den
klimawandel den scherz ich weitaus
dramatischer als das was ich mitgemacht
ehrlich gesagt
denn es gibt ja nach wegen das man nur
die die weltmeere dass sie die domain
namen meter erhöhen
was meinen sie was dann passiert wie
vielen menschen hunderte oder tausende
ihr obdach verlieren und die kommen dann
hier zu uns als flüchtlinge und werden
dann so behandelt wie die flüchtlinge
die wir jetzt hier bei herrn das gibt
wächst aus zu einer dramatik davor habe
ich angst
[Musik]
das ist kein schönes aber ein starkes
war dann ja